Donald Trump has done things that have had
far more far reaching implications and that
effect way more individual people.
But this picture and the story behind it represent
the absolute basis low of the lows of the
Trump presidency and really have Donald Trump
as a person.
Donald Trump went to El Paso, Texas to, I
guess, offer some kind of comfort to the victims
of the mass shooting that took place there
last weekend.
At least ostensibly.
That's why he was going.
Although, uh, understandably a ton of the
victims wanted nothing to do with Trump specifically
because this is the last person that's able
to offer comfort or empathy to anybody.
Uh, some of the victims reportedly just weren't
accepting visitors or weren't in a physical
condition to accept visitors.
And that's understandable as well.
So the Trump admin, uh, administration learned
about a baby that had been orphaned by the
shooting, a two month old baby, both of whose
parents had been killed in the shooting.
Donald Trump heard about this and had the
baby brought back to the hospital where Trump
was after having been discharged, the university
medical center, El Paso, and was in a truly
vile and disgusting photograph looking absolutely
thrilled with the same smile and double thumbs
up that Trump employees after you know, cheating
on a golf tournament and winning or whatever.
While Melania Trump holds the baby, this is
the epitome of a disgusting photo op.
This is not how normal people function and
how they behave in society.
A normal person wouldn't have had the baby
brought back to the hospital.
A normal person wouldn't look ecstatic to
be photographed with a baby who's entire life
has just turned upside down by the brutal
murder of both of the baby's parents.
And what's even worse is that during this
visit to El Paso, Donald Trump bragged about
the crowd size.
The last time he was in El Paso.
This video is of Trump speaking to emergency
workers, first responders, people working,
uh, hours and hours to try to clean up the
tragedy that was this horrific mass shooting,
which politically Donald Trump is unwilling
to do anything about.
Here is Donald Trump saying, you know, I had
just, just such a great crowd last time I
was here and making fun of Beto O'Rourke
was here three months ago.
We made a speech and we had a state.
What was the name of the arena?
That place was front row, right?
The judges have respected general, what was
the name?
That was some, that was some crowd and we
had twice the number of outside.
And then you had this crazy Bedo.
Bedo had like 400 people in a parking lot.
He's meeting with first responders and he
makes fun of another presidential candidate
who's actually from El Paso and who actually
shows empathy and understanding for the tragedy
that has been suffered.
And he talks about the size of his crowd the
last time that he was there.
What's most notable here is that Trump's lack
of empathy.
Is it again, like is this cognitive decline
that always comes up?
But I don't want to give Trump an easy out.
He may genuinely, genuinely just be a terrible
person who doesn't care about anybody else,
but cognitive decline comes up again.
He doesn't know to do anything other than
thumbs up and grin when a photograph is being
taken.
How sick are terrible of a person?
Do you need to be to think using an orphan
boy as a photo op prop and grinning your way
like a doofus through it is even remotely
appropriate.
And then to brag to the people there about
the size of the crowd.
The last time you were in El Paso, and it
sort of makes sense that for Donald Trump,
he thinks of all of these visits as just another
visit.
In other words, the last time Trump was in
el Paso, he had a big crowd.
He's back for another visit.
So he talks about the crowd last time.
It's no different.
That last time it was a build the wall Mageau
rally and this time it's because of a mass
shooting at which a whole bunch of people
died and were injured for Trump.
It's just another visit where he believes
himself to be the center of attention, believes
that he should be the center of attention
and believes that what everybody cares about
is getting pictures with him and hearing about
how great his last visit was and how stupid
Beto or Rourke is or whatever else.
Consider for a second who benefits from this
photo.
It's not the baby, it's not the hospital,
it's not the other victims.
This is a photo that only benefits Trump,
particularly when you consider that the baby
had already been discharged and was asked
to come back by Donald Trump and his administration.
And by the way, I mean I don't even, I don't
even know that it makes sense to go down this
road because it's just, you know, you know
where it'll go.
The baby being Hispanic, who knows how that
is going to be spun by Trump and the administration
and you know, Trump does show empathy.
It's not fair to say that Trump doesn't care
about the kids in cages.
The Latin American kids in cages look at Trump
in the picture with the baby.
Well, the baby was a prop in the picture and
Trump was grinning like a buffoon and holding
two thumbs up an unconscious unconscionably
vial moment of the Trump presidency, and there
have been many but a really summed up incredibly
concisely
by this picture.